I'm curious uh you know as someone who
supported Donald Trump in the past what
your reaction has been to the way Trump
has absorbed the DeSantis announcement
we have a clip here from Donald Trump
I'm going to play in just a second uh
that I think kind of illustrates the the
general tenor and tone that Trump has
taken so far so let's play that and then
get Dave's reaction
Rob the sanctimonious and his poll
numbers are dropping like a rock I would
almost be inclined to say these are
record Falls the question is Rob just
young and experienced a naive or more
troubling is he a fool who has no idea
what the hell he's doing how about the
fact that he had the third most deaths
of any state having to do with the China
virus or coven even Cuomo did better he
was number four and look at Disney and
what a mess it is
could have worked out an easy settlement
but no he wanted to show the fake news
how tough a guy he is
thoughts I mean everything he said there
pardon my French was just a load of
and we all know it and it's like what
I'm sick of with Trump at this point I
don't know why this clip is like even
though I've seen it 20 times it's
particularly bothering me at the moment
I've had a lot of coffee
um is that we he's a magician who we've
seen all the tricks already and he keeps
doing the same tricks and we keep
pretending as if we don't know what's
going oh there is a card up his sleeve I
can't believe it first off can can
either one of you I've been trying to
settle this on the show why is somehow
calling someone rob worse than calling
them Rob let's do that one first does
anyone does that make sense I I think
it's like he's robbing people
okay so all right fine so he's robbing
people all right that's one and then now
to sanctimonious I mean if Trump knew
what the word sanctimonious was or
sanctimony was Trump is far more
sanctimonious which is sort of fake
virtue than than Ron desantises uh next
thing he fought this we've already done
the Disney thing so you know my my
feelings on that
um and as far as the poll numbers and
and the name calling and all that you
know General really speaking when you're
30 points As Trump likes to believe he's
30 points ahead he's 40 points ahead
blah blah blah you don't relentlessly
every day have you and every single one
of your surrogates
lying repeatedly DeSantis is a rhino and
a globalist and he Sorrows back then
Paul Ryan back lying about absolutely
everything if you were so confident that
you were in the lead the way that you
purport to be so I think there's a lot
of things going on here but Zach to your
point I did support Trump last time I'm
glad that I did it I took a lot of heat
for doing it it was not easy to do in LA
I believe it was absolutely the right
thing to do I think he was for the most
part an extremely good president but
that doesn't mean he should be king and
God Emperor forever there is a better
choice right now I think I've made my
case fairly well here and and that
should be obvious to most people so I
think the choice for people if you're if
you're gonna vote Republican one way or
another you know you're a Libertarian
you've sort of had it with all these
people but you accept that you know it's
not going to be Gary Johnson again or
something what you have to decide is for
whatever your concerns are let's say on
the school choice thing that you brought
up before Nick let's let's just say even
that you're more right on that than I am
let's just pretend that's that's just
the case empirically you have to decide
okay if DeSantis has done all of these
other things and maybe I'm not
completely with him on this
I should probably vote for him because a
it'll stop the Socialists and the
Communists and God knows what's coming
behind Biden but the other opportunity
and I think this is what I think when
when some Libertarians are frustrated
with me I think this is what it hinges
on it seems obvious to me that for for
people like us who have mostly
libertarian beliefs and you just want
the government out of your life
we have a chance right now to take a guy
like DeSantis and be in the libertarian
wing of that movement there's a 50
question holy moly Magnum North uh big
Defender we all wish upon a star like
Dave Smith but we have to live in
reality if we make Trump understand what
we want I believe he will do it
okay Keep On Believing but uh I'll I
will say you know uh stop believing the
the libertarian party is obviously
another X Factor for us when we're
deciding how we as Libertarians are
going to vote
um my understanding is is Dave Smith has
declared his is candidacy uh we'll see
what else happens there but
um you know it's
it's uh I've become very cynical about
uh National level politics so I'm I
guess more open to Dave uh Dave rubin's
arguments than than I ever have been
that we kind of just at some point just
have to make a choice between really
imperfect uh offerings
um but I think it is incumbent on us to
even if we make that choice you know
hold try to hold people to the highest
standard possible I you know one of the
things I'll say is
um you know
every president going forward or almost
in every election going forward like
politicians need every vote
um and I think part of the function of
Reason uh as well as the libertarian
movement and the libertarian party and
these are all distinct things obviously
is to extract as much uh you know
concessions out of mainstream parties so
it may be you know that Libertarians
make up you know and and we Matt Welch
and I have written about this and you
know
other people have tried to document it
anywhere from about five to fifteen
percent of the of the voting population
can be considered libertarian uh meaning
you know they're generally for limited
government socially liberal fiscally
conservative however you want to slice
that up
um is you know Donald Trump the
Republicans need to pay attention to
Libertarians because Donald Trump in two
elections got 46 percent in change of
the vote he needs 50 percent any
Republican needs 50 to you know more
percent of the vote they can get
Libertarians if they say we are going to
limit the government we're going to
reduce overseas adventurism we're going
to cut spending we're going to cut
regulation we're going to be more open
to Live and Let Live all of these types
of things and you know the Democratic
party also needs us and it's you know
it's up to us to make as much noise to
say not that our votes are for sale but
like if you get in line with a general
libertarian principle about more freedom
uh and allowing a Live and Let Live
world and creating the institutions and
the policies that exemplify that you
know we're going to give you a long look
that was an excerpt from reasons live
stream with Dave Rubin if you want to
watch the whole conversation go here and
if you want to watch a different excerpt
go here and come back every Thursday at
1 pm Eastern when Zach wise Miller and I
interview somebody that you definitely
want to hear from